What is the difference between
Population
In the sample?
STAT'S EASY
The
The population is
Totality in the number of
Group that we want to study in our
Research
The sample
Is the part
o
Representative there at
Group we want to study
Let's say what you want to study in your
Research
Are the colleges
Students at
University belt
The sum of the number of colleges
Students in this area
Is the
Population
If we get some ust students
Ue and feu to answer a
Survey for our
Research
Then this is our sample
The
The population is mostly used to
National
Census of philippine
statistics
Authority
It is necessary
Account for all
People in the Philippines to count the wealth of
Population
But in
Research
Only a sample needs to be captured
It is not feasible to answer
The totality of all
That wanted
Let's study
First a lot of money is needed
To print a
Survey forms
If we target all of them
Our population
Will answer a survey
second
Big
Effort will answer all
Population
Remember that in
Research
Only limited
Time of your data collection
If you are a college
Researcher
Most likely in likely
One sem
You are the only ones reserved to collect data
But it is important to remember that the right one needs to be reached
Sample size
So that we can say that the valid
Findings of
Do your research
We will talk about this in the next videos
The research
You can do that